quick follow-up to you ari how do you
see this playing out on either side as
we approach the midterms
well yeah
i think it's one of the reasons that the
public is largely exhausted with this
and to the degree i saw a phrase this
morning that democrats are perceived as
masked fundamentalists
it just reminds people that one party
went too far had bad solutions
and refused to do sensible things
and the press plays a role here too i've
got to say they pounded republican
governors when they opened their
economies when they
stopped making with the mandates
and yet when the democrats do it the
press just gives them straightforward
news coverage it's true that hypocrisy
is is every republican knows it sees it
and the governor of texas florida
georgia they lived under it
this is part of why the democrats are in
trouble
right and kennedy but the is the cdc
however refusing to budge refusing to
account for the country's shift for what
ari is pointing out in the realm of k
through 12 students and the mask wearing
guidance in schools
the federal government has botched this
every step of the way and the fact that
we're in our third year and they're
still mishandling everything and putting
blinders on in terms of science it's
very hard to follow anyone uh when you
have a bandana over your face very very
difficult can't see rochelle wolenski
needs to resign anthony found she needs
to resign or he needs to be fired
kids are being held hostage with these
masks it doesn't make sense that you're
going to open up entire states
and go mask free but you can't in
schools where we have seen the science
has demonstrated not only our kids poor
vectors for the virus they're not
catching it the way adults are they're
not being hospitalized at nearly the
same rates and even less so now but also
johns hopkins had an exhaustive study
which we've talked about over and over
again recently that
the the mandates the lockdowns the
masking it has not worked it has not
done what it was intended to do which is
reduce mortality therefore you have to
lift all of the mass mandates and if you
have people in schools whether they're
teachers or administrators custodians
faculty or students if they're at risk
they can wear an n95 mask and do a
better job of protecting themselves
that's where we're at in the pandemic if
you feel you're at risk of getting sick
then mask yourself and do whatever you
can to make yourself safe
and harris one of everyone's favorite
democrat hypocrites however is still
holding her ground right she's
apologizing for being caught maskless
but still doubling down and say no but
kids should still wear a mask we have a
thought of that we'll play get your
thoughts on the other side
i went to read to kids for an
african-american read-in day i followed
the protocols i told the kids i'm taking
my mask off because i'm reading to kids
who are listening remotely as well
and we were socially distanced the kids
were socially distanced from me and the
excitement after i finished because it
was so much fun working with those kids
i took a picture and that was a mistake
protocols matter and protecting our kids
is the most important thing and anything
that can be perceived as undermining
that is a mistake and i apologize
which one was a mistake because now we
know that there were several pictures
you could see the montage there
this is really unfortunate because she
is one in the in the political landscape
for democrats that they were hoping had
the kind of political acumen that would
lead her to make better decisions than
this
uh and and distancing herself while
reading to kids that's one thing but
she's grouped in and lots of photos
where she's with other folk who are
masked up so either mask work or they
don't
um and in that environment where in some
states now the little ones are the only
ones who are continuing to be masked up
why wouldn't she want to also protect
them
and follow the rules it is really
mind-boggling and it's more than one
mistake it happened several times
so
you know i want to hit something that
ari said though because i think that
there is a bigger issue that we need to
pay attention to here dr wolinski today
did in fact say that local
municipalities at the local level
governors whomever
can make the decisions based on the
vaccination rates in their states and
the the numbers of cases
of covet and their states whether or not
people should have those mandates
whatever they are in place
and
she said well we continue to do that
which means it's always been so why did
president biden go after
governors that that looked at their
states i remember a point when florida
had the lowest number of cases i think
it was last summer you live there
right so so why was biden going after
those governors on mandates and things
and wanting several states to
you know put mandates in schools and and
then now he's starting to kind of say
well we were following cdc guidelines
well if the states can follow their own
guidelines based on tax rates and the
numbers of cases why can't the white
house
right the states didn't wait for the cdc
they listened to the parents that's what
i'm going to guess happen they're
listening to the constituents here and
they're also looking at the fact that
the numbers have come down they're
undeniably lower in new jersey this time
they didn't hang the flat in the curve
sign at our taxpayer expense in my
little town
but but we know that the numbers are
down so i'm just curious does biden get
a pass for that for going after these
governors i mean the courts certainly
knew it the whole time and that was the
argument in so many of these states that
said this is constitutionally a matter
of of local and state authority because
it is not it's not assigned specifically
to the federal government right that's
why case law supported all of the things
that local that the local republican
elected officials were putting forth but
now it seems that memory is short and
the issue really to this point is is
science and wait i want to interrupt
interrupt myself for a second to say
that if that was the case as well why
did states like virginia pass a law that
said well we will follow the cdc
guidelines whatever the cdc does for our
schools right like somewhere in that
entire translation the federal
government browbeat a lot of these
states into thinking that they
absolutely had no power but the ones
that resisted the ones that knew are the
ones that succeeded but they were
trusting the scientists too they were
trusting the scientists at the cdc not
to be political not to to constantly
show us the sausage making which maybe
only benefited politics like i'm fine
with it being fluid and all of that
right yeah but if the only thing that
fluidity gets you is a change in
messaging right to some political end
i'm not in favor of that so i heard you
make that point last hour and it
occurred to me as i'm in my office i
madly emailed the producers oh my gosh
we got to find the sound bite harris
just made an excellent point about the
way
about the way governor desantis was
treated among others let's roll the tape
this is how biden used to talk about
these governors
yeah these masks make a difference the
last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take off your mask
forget it it still matters
neanderthal thinking
is governor phil murphy of new jersey
who happens to have a d behind his name
for democrat is he a neanderthal is
oregon there neanderthals over there
this is so blatantly political from our
president not following the science
guess what ireland uk denmark they never
mask their children we did here in the
united states contrary to science marty
mccarry wrote in the wall street journal
yes about a north carolina study where
they looked at 90 000
cases and students and they found out a
single case of student transmission to
teachers so why are we masking our
children two words the teachers union
that is the only reason president biden
won't stand at that podium and say
unmask our children it's so political
and there will be consequences in
november to your first point that you
have to worry about and despite that
science despite that that actual science
remember the teachers walk out where the
teachers struck in uh chicago the kids
weren't remote learning then they were
just not learning but apparently there's
zero cases
the mayor said today lori lightfoot in
chicago she's blaming the high number of
carjackings on remote learning oh my
gosh you can't even make that up
and it's sad it's sad in any regard but
that's how far and ari put it so well
that's where we've traveled to we have
to to respect the fact that we're not
where we were two years ago
exactly well we're not but i think a lot
of the democrats unfortunately are
they're in that same spot